alors loïc je vous demandais quelque
chose oui vous êtes vraiment très très
gros danseurs nous un très grand danseur
et si il est à côté tu es blessé
il s'appelle mathieu de là est née une
bête blessée peux encore danser
il n'est pas de moi vous êtes bien sûr
de la victor hugo bref c'est sa merci
mais la venue alors jardy des musiques
vont s'enchaîner
il va falloir tout donner pendant une
minute trente à chaque musique bah oui
pas mal de là et on va élire le meilleur
danseur est ce que c'est notre danseurs
notre challenger celui qui a appuyé les
meilleurs celui qui donne des cours de
danse
matthieu delormeau et abb un amateur
passionné tout simple alors le public à
la fin votera avec des panneaux rouges
pour loïc et bleu pour mathieu ce que
vous avez les panneaux dans le public
oui eh bien écoutez pour une fois que
vous avez un truc dans cette émission
ça fait plaisir mais faut pas pousser
des feuilles en fait exactement le
perdant devra subir le ver des souks
ça veut dire et devra se faire zouk et
part vers des arrêts donc si je peux
vous donner un conseil ne perdez pas
c'est une horreur
attention on va démarrer tout de suite
avec loïc notez bien mme diallo
loïc mon chéri des musiques vont
s'enchaîner donne tout il faut que tu
bat mathieu delormeau tu l'as vu dans ce
bien oui à carhaix tu peux faire mieux
que lui
regardez lambert les noms mais tiennent
mito attention loïc en même temps et à
chaque scratch ouais tu changes de danse
d'accord ok lui dansera appréciez-vous
d'abord et après c'est lui vous faites
une minute trente
on est parti c'est là
non
allez
m
moi
dans
de l'agglo
mathieu est ce qui vous a impressionné
bachas riboud d'impressionner françois
non non attention il va jouer blessé
ouais le public va voter ensuite
pouvaient voter également si vous sur
twitter #bastarache mettant vos beauté
c'est parti batasuna
les vols attention et me laisser une
minute c'est même une minute trente pour
faire rêver la france ce sont les mêmes
musiques et il ya du mylène farmer bébé
j'ai pensé à toi il faut choisir
à mon tour je peux le dire c'est un
autre façon je suis un garçon et au
chaton tutorat des verrues on y va
le
et
non
oui
le chou
non
je
à
ah ah
et
à
là alors je m'appelle avant avant
d'avoir les votes du public loïc est ce
que vous avez quelque chose à dire sur
la prestation est d'aller sur votre
prestation sur celle de matthieu mais je
vais avoir dû remettre ça j'aimerais
vraiment maintenant c'est la première
page madonna sonarges danser sur un jack
homme est alors mathieu et vous jetez
blessés [ __ ] de blessure soul que
j'aime c'est tout ce que je lui dis
alors le public pleuve ou mathieu rouge
paulo ic attention c'est parti
oui alors c'est matthieu delormeau qu'à
gagner alors malheureusement
le pot ce que vous avez fait danse avec
les stars event and for nature là vous
savez ghani filet dans une fugue à
bateaux tous les samedis soirs il fait
des danses mon frère on est devant au 10
mai saint génis noté et là il arrive et
alors que marc guillemot ma vie s'il est
blessé et vous vous ne trouvez pas que
c'est un grand danseur loïc ainsi un
très grand ce loïc malheureusement vous
avez perdu ses publics qualifiés donc
vous allez devoir faire
vous dansez généralement avec qui dans
danse avec les stars dennis dennis arena
des mix à la danseuse bien sûr pas le
yaourt
vous allez devoir danser avec l'année
avec cette personne yasuko très
particulier pour taxer que c'est c'est
le zouk verdez c'est un zouk très très
chaud venez vous rejoins nous y sommes
alors qu'est ce que vous aimez le zouk
loïc sur un zoom agréable et gilles
verdez et loïc noter c'est parti allez
merci mollo nivet côté nos pauvres il
vient et fictif là-bas et liveside horse
avec leopard trek déni de sa résidence
avec oh là là là ça va loin il est
content d'être venu nous voir louis
quand même tu as fait une très belle
émission qu'il a tout donné les japonais
merci d'être là de faire beaucoup non
dans touche pas à mon poste vraiment et
vous êtes un très grand chanteur aussi
on vous a vu à leur revient oui j'ai
adoré votre chanson judas faut pour vous
vous avez bien figure il était devant
mouvement free a fini 4e et 5e 4e leur
mit un tabouret pour enfants parce que
là vous vous éclatez dans danse avec les
stars on vous retrouve donc tous les
samedis soir vous avez vraiment envie de
gagner
je le sens bien ou de m'amuser avant
mais voilà vous êtes très soutenu les
les filles vous adorez non mais c'est
vrai mais vraiment je dois aussi un bel
homme
il